so then from that experience i believe
your two sisters began their own sort of
organization to help other seniors can
you talk about that
yeah they wanted to help other seniors
get online so my two sisters started
going to a local retirement residence
and giving the seniors lessons and they
started just asking their school friends
people in their classes if they wanted
to tag along and i think there was a
group of about 15 of them that would go
to the retirement residence two days a
week after school and give hour long
lessons to the seniors what was in it
for
you know i'm dating myself calling them
the young people but the younger
generation the millennials or the
generation y people that
what did they feel compelled to to give
back to these seniors what was the
reason i think the main driving reason
for a lot of the students who join in
this program in the beginning is taking
on a leadership role in their
communities
which looks really great on college
applications and job applications so
my sisters also did it for community
service hours they needed to get 100
community service hours in order to
graduate high school so they were
looking for interesting ways to help out
in their community
but i think you know once the students
get into it they end up teaching for
longer than they need to to fulfill
those 100 hours community service
because they just enjoy it i mean it's
fun and i think they start to realize
they really like helping out in their
community and this is something that
comes naturally to them so it's not a
difficult thing for them to do to give
these computer lessons
yeah cyber seniors show such great
moments between the two generations on
the computer and you did see this
relationship develop amongst all of them
and it was it was really sweet to see
you know how quote faster the younger
generation was and then the older
generation was oh how did you do that
you make this go so fast please you know
and it was great to see the relationship
between the two of them
how did
the seniors sign up like what was their
reasoning they hear about the internet
it sounds like they were scared of it a
little bit but they were still intrigued
what was their reasoning did they tell
you yeah i think for a lot of them they
they hear so much about the internet
they say you know my kids live in front
of their computers my grandkids live in
front of their computers and i don't
know anything about it
i want to know a little bit more about
what's going on definitely the driving
factor for them was getting in touch
with family they wanted to they see
their grandkids on facebook all the time
so they want to be on facebook too they
want to be able to skype with them and
communicate with them
you